Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaosradio 271 mit einem Thema, von dem ihr sicherlich noch gar nichts gehört habt und das euer Herz hoch erfreut, wenn ihr es hört. Es geht um Cybersicherheitspolitik im Rahmen der Bundestagswahl. Ja, es ist notwendig. Man würde es eigentlich den Leuten gerne ersparen, aber das geht nicht, weil es ja verschiedene Aspekte gibt, die möglicherweise für eine Wahlentscheidung ausschlaggebend sind. Und dann ist klar, also gut, Chaosradio macht dann wahrscheinlich sozusagen nicht den Teil, wo wir die Erde mit Klimaschutz retten, auch wichtig, sondern irgendwas mit dem Digitalen. Aber selbst das ist mittlerweile so groß, dass eine Sendung, vielleicht würde man es schaffen, aber die Gehirne werden danach weich. Deswegen konzentrieren wir uns heute auf ein Thema, nämlich Cybersicherheitspolitik. Was das genau ist, muss ich gleich noch fragen. Und dazu begrüße ich recht herzlich Honkaase. Hallo. Wer ist das? Honkaase kennt ihr vielleicht von vergangenen Chaosradio Sendungen. Das letzte Mal als wir uns gehört haben, war es, glaube ich, kritische Infrastruktur und warum das auch wichtig ist. Markus ist auch k.o. macht Datenschutzdinger und IT-Krams. Und man hat in der letzten Zeit vielleicht von ihm gehört, weil er sehr umtriebig auch ist öffentlich. Und Anna ist bei netzpolitik.org CVD gerade, vor allem. Also man liest gerade nicht so viel von ihr, weil sie an der Front sitzt. Also wenn ich zum Beispiel einen Radiobeitrag mache, dann gehe ich zum CVD und dann sagt er, also hier musst du aber noch. Er sagt meistens im Prinzip gut, aber... Und dann, naja gut, das ist eine andere Geschichte. Wir wollen heute über Cyber-Sicherheitspolitik reden. Und vielleicht könnt ihr euch gleich noch mal vorstellen, mit eurer liebsten Cyber-Sicherheitspolitik-Geschichte, mit der ihr persönlich zu tun hattet, im Rahmen der letzten Legislaturperiode. Honkase.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist einfach. Ich habe mich gequält durch das IT-Sicherheitsgesetz 2.0 im Entstehungsprozess, in dem ganzen Hirnwindungs-Diffusionskonstrukt, was dann die Regierung daraus veranstaltet hat und das Bundesinnenministerium. Und dann war ich zuletzt als Sachverständiger bei der IT-Sicherheitsgesetz 2.0 Anhörung im Bundestag und habe es wie alle anderen fünf Sachverständigen genauso in der Luft zerrissen. Das hat aber das Innenministerium nicht viel interessiert und es hat im Wesentlichen dieses Desolate-Konstrukt so ins Laufen gebracht, wie sie es eingangs quasi angekündigt haben und umsetzen wollten.
Okay, dann darüber werden wir sicherlich noch gleich genauer reden.
Anna?
Liebling ist so ein bisschen schwierig, wenn man das irgendwie so sagen will. Ich glaube, was mich am meisten aufgeregt hat, vielleicht kann man das auch sagen, ich reg mich auch gerne auf, ist, dass es immer noch den Satz gibt, Sicherheit durch Verschlüsselung und Sicherheit trotz Verschlüsselung. Das ist mein Alltime-Favorite in der Cybersicherheitspolitik, glaube ich.
Okay, aber gab es da für einen konkreten Anlass oder einfach weil das immer wieder passiert ist?
Nee, das passiert einfach immer wieder. Das passiert bei möglichen Sachen, wenn man dann irgendwie im Digitalen das Gleiche machen darf wie im Analogen, weil das dann immer wieder so schön verglichen wird. Generell komische, unfassende Metaphern immer wieder gut.
Das heißt, wenn man daraus ein Trinkspiel gemacht hat, wärst du jetzt Alkoholikerin im Rahmen der letzten Legislaturperiode?
Ja, ich mach das einfach mit Kaffee, dann hab ich irgendwie Herzrasen, aber das kriege ich auch so, das ist okay.
Okay, Markus, wie war es bei dir?
Ich würde vielleicht die 5G-Hurweidebate nehmen, weil das fand ich echt lustig sozusagen vom Thema her. Es hat auch eine überraschende Breite genommen. Auch Außenpolitiker haben sich plötzlich zu Cyberpolitik unterhalten und es ist ja dann auch in diversen Richtlinien, Sicherheitskatalogen und Gesetzen nachher sozusagen widergespiegelt worden. Das heißt, das fand ich eine neue Debatte im Sicherheitsbereich.
Okay, so vielleicht könnten wir jetzt sozusagen, bevor wir uns in die Untiefen, in all diese Dinge hineinbegeben, noch mal kurz klären, also ihr klären, worüber reden wir heute und worüber reden wir heute nicht? Also ich glaube, wir reden heute zum Beispiel nicht über sowas wie den Infrastrukturaufbau. Es gab das schöne Zitat, 5G an jeder Milchkarte und so. Da reden wir aber nicht drüber. Wir reden, glaube ich, auch nicht über KI oder digitale Bildung, sondern worüber reden wir oder andersherum gefragt, was genau ist eigentlich eine Cyber-Sicherheitspolitik? Also was beinhaltet die und wo sind ihre Grenzen?
Ich glaube, wenn wir das wüssten, wären wir schon weiter. Ich glaube, das Problem ist einfach die Cyber-Sicherheit oder generell alles, was mit Cyber zu tun hat. Niemand weiß dann am Ende so richtig, was es ist. Und dann fragt man sich manchmal, also ich frage mich ganz oft bei dieser ganzen Cyber-Sicherheitsdebatte, ob jetzt eigentlich es darum geht, den Staat vor dem bösen Cyber zu schützen oder tatsächlich irgendwie die IT-Welt sicherer zu machen und damit eben alle Personen. Ich glaube, das ist so das Kernproblem, dass einfach auch nicht ganz klar ist, worüber man redet.
Da gibt es auch sozusagen verschiedene Ziele. Also sozusagen die einen sagen, wir möchten gerne IT-Sicherheit haben, wir möchten gerne, dass Systeme nicht angreifbar sind. Gleichzeitig fasst man aber dann darunter auch Überwachung von Cyber-Kriminellen oder den Staatszoianer oder andere online Überwachungsmöglichkeiten. Das hat einen bunten Strauß an verschiedenen Maßnahmen, die man darunter packt, um zu sagen, man hat eine Strategie. Da hat man sich noch nicht wirklich abgegrenzt, wo jetzt sozusagen das Ziel ist, weil verschiedene Ministerien verschiedene Ziele verfolgen im Rahmen der Cyber-Sicherheitsstrategie. Ich denke, es ist auch das Thema Verschlüsselung.
Genau. Und ich denke, es ist auch so, dass wenn man von Sicherheit redet, dann ist auch die Frage, wer redet davon und welchen Kontext meint diese Person dann. Wenn zum Beispiel das Innenministerium ist, dann reden die in der Regel nicht von IT-Sicherheit, so wie jetzt viele Aktivistinnen, die Sicherheitsforscherinnengemeinde oder der CCC oder wer auch immer. Die reden bei IT-Sicherheit oder bei Sicherheit im Netz oder Cybersicherheit immer von IT-Sicherheit und das Bundesinnenministerium in der Regel eher von innerer Sicherheit. Und damit das, was Markus gerade meinte, nämlich von Überwachung, von Vorratsdatenspeicherung, von diesem unsäglichen Sicherheit durch Verschlüsselung, Sicherheit trotz Verschlüsselung. Also wir gucken rein, aber gucken nicht rein, aber irgendwie doch. Und das ist durchaus ein absichtliches, anderes Narrativ, was da gefüttert wird. Und deswegen ist Cybersicherheitspolitik, glaube ich, auch nicht klar definierbar, weil sie das absichtlich in diese andere Kontextbetrachtung werfen.
Das hat auch international verschiedene Bedeutungen. Wenn man diesen Bereich Informationssicherheit nimmt, dann haben andere Staaten öfter mal die Vorstellung, dass man hier über den Schutz vor Informationen redet oder auch die Kontrolle von Informationen. Also gerade die Beispiele wie China, dass Informationen kontrolliert werden, ist ja noch eine andere Herangehensweise als hier mit der Presse oder mit dem freien Internet.
Also ich versuch's ja dann immer aus der Perspektive des Einzelnen zu sehen, in diesem Fall also die WD-A-Innen. Und würde jetzt denken, das sind also irgendwie drei Themen. Das eine ist, wie wird Verstößlung slash Überwachung organisiert? Also ich sag jetzt erst mal wertneutral, also will man das oder nicht? Und wenn ja, wie macht man das? Wenn nein, wie verhindert man das und so weiter und so fort? Das ist der eine Punkt. Der andere Punkt ist tatsächlich Sicherheit, also Gewährleistung von Sicherheit, also die digitale Welt, in der wir leben. Wie wird die möglichst sicher gehalten? Da reden wir dann wahrscheinlich über Sicherheitslücken und was sozusagen da gemacht werden kann oder halt nicht gemacht werden kann. Und das dritte ist dann, das finde ich ganz spannend, das ist schon aber auch irgendwie digitale Infrastruktur. Ich habe es gerade vollmündig angekündigt. Wir reden jetzt nicht über den Breitbandausbau, aber sozusagen über die Art und Weise, wie die digitale Infrastruktur des Landes, also die, das überhaupt alles möglich machen, organisiert ist, muss man doch eigentlich, wenn man sozusagen bundespolitisch spricht, auch reden, oder?
Ja, schon.
Yes, no. Also ich denke, das sagen Huawei-Themate und so, die zielt auch gerade genau darauf ab, oder?
Ja, das war sozusagen schon so ein Thema, wo man sagt, okay, hier möchte man irgendwie Staat, Wirtschaft und Gesellschaft auch verschützen, von externen Akteuren verwundbar zu sein oder angriffen werden zu können. Und das hat ja auch vor allem so einen starken, weltweiten politischen Ausschlag gehabt, wo dann sozusagen die USA gesagt haben, okay, wir möchten gerne, dass China nicht im Westen Geräte ausrollt.
Lass uns einfach damit anfangen. Ich wollte nur noch mal, also ich als Wähler, wenn wir jetzt hier drüber reden, was ja vielleicht möglicherweise gibt in Empfehlungen, aber soll vor allen Dingen eine Hilfe zur Entscheidung sein. Also wenn ich wähle, wem bekomme das? Das sind so die drei Themen, die ich da sehe. Und eine Frage noch, wenn wir jetzt über die vergangene Legislaturperiode sprechen, sprechen wir dann vor allen Dingen über das, was die Regierung gemacht hat, also CDU und SPD, oder spielt die Opposition da irgendwie auch eine Rolle in dem, was sie gemacht hat oder in dem, was sie hätte machen können? Oder ist es sozusagen, wenn wir jetzt über die letzten vier Jahre reden, dann ist es sowieso nur GroKo?
Gefühlt ist es nur GroKo, weil die alles im Eigenpanorama durchgezogen hat und alle Kritik oder auch Oppositionen an an sehr vielen Stellen komplett ignoriert hat.
Würde ich auch so sehen. Gab es da viele gute Anträge und Ideen, die da auch vorgeschlagen worden sind. Auch von allen Oppositionsparteien. Aber das Doing war dann aus Seiten der Regierung.
Okay, aber das ist ja dann doch interessant. Also sagen, wenn es von einer anderen politischen Partei eine gute Idee gab, wäre es ja vielleicht für mich als Wähler dann doch interessant zu wissen. Da haben Leute sich hingestellt und die hatten anscheinend Ahnung von irgendwas. Vielleicht, also wenn euch das zwischendurch auffällt, könntest du ja sozusagen uns mit reingeben. So, Huawei-Debatte. Ich hab die ehrlich gesagt, als die stattfand, war ich gerade sozusagen in meinem Arbeitskontext so ein bisschen outside und war sehr froh, dass die Kollegen sich darum gekümmert haben. Deswegen weiß ich nur noch, also in meinem Kopf ist nur noch, es geht darum, 5G, schnelles Internet, das sind wir wieder, wollen wir alle haben, 5G-Ausbau. Und dann war die Frage, wer macht das? Also welche Hardware hängt dann wirklich in den Sendemasten? Und dann gab es also die, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man es sagen soll, Angsttheorie. Wenn Huawei das macht, dann hängen wir uns quasi die chinesische Regierung an die Sendemasten und dann wird alles schlimm. Vielleicht könnt ihr das noch mal ein bisschen aus Füchern schreiben. Was ist da, warum, mit wem passiert?
Aus meiner Sicht hat das quasi in den USA angefangen, dass dort der Handelskrieg mit China ja schon bestand, mit den Zöllen, die Trump damals erhoben hat und China dann ebenfalls. Und da gab es dann auch so eine Debatte um die jetzt neuen 5G-Netzte und den Ausbau von 5G. Und da war natürlich Huawei einer der großen Player am Markt, der ja auch sozusagen von der Regierung subventioniert wurde, hat also sehr günstig seine Produkte anbieten können und dann gab es sozusagen diverse Kampagnen, dass jetzt westliche Staaten nicht mehr auf chinesische Technologie setzen sollten, sondern auf sichere westlichere Techniken und Produkte. Und dann haben Botschafter in verschiedenen Ländern sozusagen echt eine Kampagne gefahren, um halt andere Staaten dazu zu motivieren, sich auch gegen Huawei zu äußern. Das war dann in Australien der Fall, in Japan, in Korea, Großbritannien. Und natürlich gab hier in ganz Deutschland auch diese Debatte und die hat dann doch ein recht großes Fass aufgemacht. Da hat man quasi das Innenministerium, was sich hier sozusagen um Sicherheit gekümmert hat, das Wirtschaftsministerium, was sich dann schützend vor die Tecos gestellt hat und das Außenministerium, was quasi auch noch mal eine Position dazu haben wollte, dass man quasi über drei, vier verschiedene Bundestagsausschüsse das Thema spielen konnte. Und dann gab es so Gerüchteküchen wie, wenn die Chinesen kommen, dann haben sie dann ein Kill-Switch drin oder die haben dann Zugriff auf diverse Dinge.
Ein was drin?
Ein Kill-Switch, also eine Möglichkeit von außen, das Mobilfunknetz abzuschalten. Und natürlich gab es dann die Forderung, dass man jetzt nur noch von vertrauenswürdigen Herstellern einkauft, mit vertrauenswürdiger Hardware. Oder am besten noch irgendein Prüflabor, was das dann zertifizieren soll. Also wie man sich das halt so vorstellt, wenn man nie mit IT zu tun hat. Und da gab es noch die Forderung, ob man Produkte jetzt nach dem Herkunftsland noch sortiert. Also Produkte aus China sind schon mal nicht vertrauenswürdig und Produkte aus den USA sind vertrauenswürdig. Auch wenn vielleicht beide Backdoors haben. Also das war schon eine sehr fiese Geschichte, da einzelne Länder auszusuchen und gleichzeitig dann aber auch keine fachlichen Gründe anführen zu können, warum das jetzt unsicher ist. Also wenn man jetzt sagen würde, okay, wir haben da ein paar Dinge gefunden, die wurden nicht gepatcht, das ist eine Backdoor, dann kann man es ja nachvollziehen. Oder vielleicht leuchtet einem auch ein, dass man im Mobilfunknetz jetzt nicht die Geräte, die man anschließt, unmittelbar ins Internet hängt, sondern dass wir vielleicht doch eher ein Kernnetz haben, was noch abgeschottet ist, wo der Hersteller keinen direkten Zugriff drauf hat. Das waren quasi alles Argumente, die dann in der öffentlichen Debatte gar nicht mehr stattgefunden haben, sondern da haben dann Außenpolitiker darüber gesprochen, wo die Geräte herkamen und wo das Gerät herkommt, ist dann auch eine Bewertung, wie sicher es ist.
Ich muss jetzt mal die ganze Frage stellen, ist es völlig von der Hand zu weisen, dass es nicht so ist? Also wenn ich dich jetzt richtig interpretiere, ist es so, das ist reiner Protektionismus. Da geht es um die wirtschaftlichen Gründe und Wirtschaftsförderung, sozusagen nicht um das, so hört es sich für mich jetzt an, vorgeschobene Thema. Aber andererseits fragt man sich schon, naja, also irgendwie, vielleicht gibt es ja doch eine politische Motivation zumindest, dass das nicht undenkbar ist. Wie schätzt ihr das denn ein?
Also die politische Motivation, die gibt es ja auf jeden Fall und die gibt es ja auch in anderen Ländern. Wir haben ja schon Backdoors in amerikanischem Equipment gefunden, wo sogar nachgewiesen wurde, dass Backdoors sind. Das ist ja nicht die Frage. Die Frage ist, welches Ziel versuchst du denn mit einer solchen Debatte den Gesetzen drumherum, vertrauenswürdige Hersteller zu erreichen? Wenn man sich diesen vertrauenswürdigen Herstellerprozessablauf der sozusagen im IT-Sicherheitsgesetz II beschrieben ist, anschaut, stellt man relativ schnell fest, da steht so Vichy Vachy drin. Wir wollen, dass die irgendwie so eine Absolution durch eine eigene Zertifizierung und eine Unterschrift und sind dann rechtskräftig sozusagen sauber. Und ein Geheimdienst von den Chinesen oder auch den Amerikanern, um einfach mal auch das Gegenbild aufzuzeigen, würde trotzdem eine Manipulation vornehmen. Das ist ja nicht der Akt. Aber bevor die das tun, muss man ja erstmal überlegen, was wäre der einfachste Angriffsweg für eine böswillige Regierung, die in fremden Netzen einen Kill-Switch oder einen Zugriff haben will. Da gehst du nicht über die Komponente selbst. Das machst du vielleicht, wenn du doof bist. Aber wenn du intelligent bist, pfeifst du auf das Gerät und kompromittierst sozusagen den Subdienstleister, der diese Core-Infrastrukturkomponenten ins Core-Netz reinhängt. Das machen nämlich nicht mehr Telekom, Vodafone und wie sie nicht alle heißen selber. Die holen sich dann Subdienstleister, die schrauben den Kram ins Rack. Und das sind dann kleine Buden mit irgendwie komischen Leuten. Und da schleust du dann einen ein oder bestichs ein und schwuppbisse im Kernnetz drin. Und hast jemand direkt da am Herzstück? Wo ist denn da der Akt? Also da brauchst du doch gar nicht diese Riesenaufwandszeremonie betreiben. Das ist also alles tatsächlich eher vorgeschobenes Argument. Protektionismus, Geopolitik und ein bisschen Vichy Vachy. Aber ein echter Schutz so richtig strukturiert und nachgedacht und vollständig liefert das leider nicht. Und also nur damit wir einen Kontext haben, ich beziehe mich auf den § 9b im BSI-Gesetz, da wo diese vertrauenswürdigen Hersteller beschrieben sind und dass man diese ganze Wertenschöpfungskette absichert.
Und dieses Gesetz ist jetzt neu?
Das ist im IT-Sicherheitsgesetz 2.0 verabschiedet worden. Und da das ein Artikelgesetz ist, heißt es, es werden mehrere Gesetze gleichzeitig verändert, weil sonst...
Warte, warte, warte. Das geht mir alles viel zu schnell. Das geht mir alles viel zu schnell. Also wir sind jetzt gerade noch bei Huawei. Und der Aufhängung, ob die Frage, wie das ist, wenn neue Infrastruktur gebaut wird. Da ist jetzt erstmal... Da habt ihr jetzt gerade gesagt, naja, das ist mal aus einer technischen Perspektive gesehen eigentlich Quatsch. Da geht es um was anderes.
Okay.
Was ich mich jetzt frage ist, ist das was, was jedes Mal diskutiert wird, wenn ein neues Gehe zum Beispiel ausgehängt wird oder so? Weil ich würde ja eigentlich denken, jetzt gibt es ja nicht erst seit gestern digitale Infrastruktur, dass das sowas vielleicht schon vorher geregelt wurde oder war das einfach so Learning by Doing?
Das war jetzt quasi neu, weil ja im Rahmen der Politik 5G was völlig Neues ist und nicht einfach nur ein Versionswechsel im Protokoll, sondern das wird ja quasi vom Marketing verkauft als was völlig Neues. Und dann gab es zeitgleich noch diese Debatte rund um das IT-Sicherheitsgesetz und dann war es ja sehr praktisch, dass man dann gleich in dem IT-Sicherheitsgesetz auch noch was unterbringen konnte, um dieses Thema ausländische Herstellerregeln zu können.
Okay, weitere Verständnisfrage. War es jetzt wirklich was Neues oder nicht? Also weil es gab jetzt wie viele verschiedene Mobilfunk, also Internetübertragungs-Mobilfunk-Dinger gibt es vier, oder? GPRS, Edge, LTE und jetzt 5G, ne? Nee, da fehlt doch noch eins.
Was ist die Version 13 und 14 von dem entsprechenden Zweck?
Also diese Dinger sozusagen. Und da hätte ich jetzt gedacht, da ist jedes Mal neue Hardware installiert worden. Aber das stimmt gar nicht.
2G, 3G mindestens ist ja ein gemeinsamer Hardware gewesen, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Und für 5G brauchste neue Komponenten. Es hat aber auch deutlich komplexere Software-Funktionalitäten drin. Und damit auch einhergehend deutlich mehr Sicherheitsaspekte, die rein integriert wurden. Und so ein bisschen auch das Problem hatten, dass Sicherheitsbehörden sagen, da haben wir auch so eine Art Going Dark. Wir brauchen dringend laufende Interception-Schnittstellen und diverses anderes. Das waren 5G deutlich mehr als in den vorherigen.
Da muss ich an dieser Stelle falle ich in ein weiteres Rappen holen. Was heißt Going Dark? Das heißt sozusagen, in dem 5G ist mehr Möglichkeit versteckt, dass Kommunikation sofort auf dieser technischen Ebene schon verschüsselt wird?
Das 5G hat Optionen, dass das Handy einen Mobilfunkmast autentifizieren kann. Das heißt, es kann prüfen, ist das der echte Funkmast von dem Teleco-Provider. Bislang hat die Polizei sehr gerne mit IMSI-Catchern gearbeitet, also einem Gerät, das einen gefälschten Mobilfunkturm aufgemacht hat, damit sich dann die Handys in der Umgebung damit verbinden, um dort quasi den Datenverkehr mitlesen zu können. Da gab es dann Befürchtungen, dass das mit 5G nicht mehr möglich sein würde. Das heißt, going dark, die Dienste würden weniger sehen, würden im Dunkeln stehen, hätten weniger Aufklärung, weil quasi neue Sicherheitsfunktionen die Überwachung erschweren.
So, und dann zurück zu der anderen Frage. Also ja, das ist neue Technologie, aber für andere Mobilfunknetzstandards ist auch schon mal Technologie aufgehangen worden. Daher nochmal die Frage, da muss es doch schon vorher Regelungen gegeben haben, wie sowas vonstatten geht, wie da was zertifiziert wird, wie da festgelegt wird, wer das machen darf.
Maybe? Nicht so großartig, nee.
Genau.
Die Techies waren ja relativ frei darin, welche Hersteller sie jetzt benutzen. Da gab es sozusagen ja grundlegende Sicherheitskataloge für die Provider, aber das ging bisher nicht so weit, dass ihnen vorgeschrieben worden ist, welches Produkt sie benutzt werden. Es gab ja auch immer die Forderung, dass sie keine Monokulturen bauen, sondern dass sie verschiedene Hersteller benutzen. Und es ist halt bei der Zahl der Anbieter von Mobilfunkprodukten gar nicht so einfach, keine Monokulturen zu bauen, wenn man auf Huawei verzichten soll.
Und es gab sogar als Addon einen, ich glaube, der hieß Brandbrief oder so von der Telekom, die dann gesagt hat, Leute, wenn ihr Huawei verbieten wollt, kostet uns das mal gepflegte 4 Milliarden, weil wir hier alles rausrupfen und neu machen müssten, weil wir große Teile auf Huawei betreiben, ist euch das irgendwie klar? Das finden wir nicht lustig so.
Ich tippe mal, das war Ihnen nicht klar.
Ja, was ich an der Diskussion halt auch so ein bisschen schwierig fand, wo ich mir dachte, auf welche Ebene wollen sie denn runtergehen? Also das heißt, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie kein Gerät von Huawei benutzen darf, aber darf ich jetzt irgendwas benutzen, wo ein Chip von einem chinesischen Hersteller drin ist? Und was mache ich denn, wenn ich das nicht mehr darf? Also ich fand das einfach so eine Scheindiskussion, weil sich das ja im Endeffekt eh nicht regeln lässt. Und für mich war das nicht nur so, also in der Wahrnehmung, nicht nur so ein geopolitisches, da sind die bösen Chinesen und da müssen wir jetzt irgendwie was gegen machen, sondern auch tatsächlich eher so ein verzweifelter Versuch, so eine Stärkung von westlichen Lieferanten künstlich herbeizuführen, wenn sie dann im Zweifelsfall bevorzugt werden müssten. Und das fand ich eben auch ein bisschen schwierig und sehr künstlich am Ende. Und dann auch das, was dabei rausgekommen ist, zu sagen, okay, kritische Komponenten müssen gemeldet werden, ist halt auch die Frage, bis auf welche Ebene man das irgendwie sagt. Müssen sie jetzt irgendwie eine komplette Teileliste liefern? Oder eben nicht? Also was passiert denn am Ende wirklich in der Praxis?
In der politischen Diskussion darum, die Herr Stadtgefunden hat, haben sich da die im Bundestag vertretenen Parteien mit Ruhm bekleckert? Oder haben die da alle mehr oder weniger im Dark rumgefischt?
Das war größtenteils so ein GroKo-Ding, weil die halt die Linien der Ministerien geschützt haben. Aber zum Teil gab es ja auch sozusagen zwischen den Ministerien starke Widersprüche. Also das Wirtschaftsministerium und das BMI, die haben sich da schon ziemlich widersprochen in ihren Aussagen.
Ich hab jetzt gerade das Wirtschaftsministerium verstanden.
Das war ja sozusagen zuständig für die Telcos und hatte daher auch natürlich die Schützen der Hand über die Telekom. Und denen gefiel natürlich so eine Vorschrift überhaupt nicht, wenn das halt viel Geld kosten würde und den 5G-Ausbau ausbremsen würde. Da gab es sozusagen auch Konflikte innerhalb der CDU.
Okay, dann hat man also versucht, das im Rahmen dieses Gesetzes zu lösen, was sozusagen noch eine Nummer größer war. Vielleicht könnten wir es so machen, dass ihr erst mal ganz kurz sagt, was dieses Gesetz ist, und dann kehren wir noch mal zu dem Punkt zurück, was zu diesem Thema da drin stand, also das IT-Sicherheitsgesetz. Du meinst, wir sollten lieber erst besprechen, was da drin steht zunächst und dann über das große Ganze reden?
Ich weiß nicht, ich finde es tatsächlich ein ganz interessantes Gesetz, weil es einfach so eine super lange Entstehungsgeschichte hat und währenddessen einfach so extrem viele andere Sachen, eingeflossene Sachen gestrichen wurden. Und am Ende kam irgendwas dabei raus, und dann hat man zwischendurch noch mal einen neuen Anlauf gemacht. Also sie haben ja schon sehr, sehr früh angefangen, das IT-Sicherheitsgesetz.
Warte, warte, warte, warte, bevor du jetzt anfängst. Wir müssen ja trotzdem, pass auf, wir machen was anderes. Ihr sagt jetzt noch schnell, wie die Geschichte mit dem Huawei in 5G ausgegangen ist. Und dann machen wir dieses Gesetz einmal von vorne.
Na, es ist so ausgegangen, dass jetzt im IT-Sicherheitsgesetz 2 dieser... Aufgrund des IT-Sicherheitsgesetzes 2 so rum, im BSI-Gesetz, der § 9b drinsteht, die Lex-Hua-Wei-Klausel, dass man vertrauenswürdige Hersteller von kritischen Komponenten nutzen muss. Und nach Telekommunikationsgesetz, § 109 war es glaube ich, die kritischen Funktionen definiert. Und diese Liste der kritischen Funktionen ist vor ein paar Tagen erst verabschiedet worden. Welche Kategorie, welche Funktionalität in 5G ist kritisch? Und die muss man dann mit diesem vertrauenswürdigen Hersteller Klimbimse bestätigen. Und dann hat man seinen Pflicht erfüllt und darf mitspielen. Oder das BMI geht hin und sagt, wir haben ja aber ein Veto und finden das schlimm. Und deswegen wollen wir diesen Hersteller nicht zulassen.
Also jetzt abgesehen von dem letzten Ding, das du gerade gesagt hast, doch der Rest dabei jetzt hört sich sinnvoll an oder nicht? Dass man sagt, also wenn wir hier sozusagen Infrastruktur aufbauen, dann wollen wir auch gucken, dass das gutes Zeug ist.
Ja, dann müsste man diese BMI behält sich eine Veto-Klausel, wenn jemand politisch unliebsam ist, weglassen und tatsächlich alle gleich behandeln. Und wie gesagt, wenn man auch das, was Anna sagte, du kannst nicht versuchen zu schützen und BCDE nicht, chinesische Chips nicht, aber chinesische Hersteller doch. Und ich habe ja gerade ein paar Szenarien genannt, wie man ganz einfach doch in das Kernnetz kommen könnte. Da braucht man diesen ganzen Zertifizierungsklimb nicht für. Das ist kein vollständiger sinnvoller Sicherheitsansatz, sondern eher ein, wir schieben Sicherheit vor für geowirtschaftspolitische Fragestellungen. Und damit kann man, ich sage jetzt mal ganz überspitzt, konservative CDU-Wähler glücklich machen und Sicherheitsbehörden. Fertig.
Also, was bruche ich mal unter nicht unbedingt mit Ruhm bekleckert. So, das IT-Sicherheitsgesetz. Wer, was, warum, woher? Eine lange Geschichte. Eine Geschichte voller Missverständnis.
Ich glaube, da kann man ja schon mal irgendwie anfangen zu sagen, es gab irgendwie schon ein erstes IT-Sicherheitsgesetz. Das ist schon mittlerweile sechs Jahre her, wenn ich nicht ganz skifliege. Und dann hat man, ja, dann war es notwendig, das anzupassen, unter anderem auch aufgrund von EU-Vorgaben. Und dann hat man aber dann einen Entwurf gemacht, den hatten wir damals irgendwie 2019 veröffentlicht, das heißt auch schon vor einer ganzen, ganzen Weile. Und da standen dann diverse Dinge drin, die man so erwarten würde. Das heißt irgendwie diverse Regelungen zum Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik, dass die irgendwie plötzlich mehr Dinge dürfen sollen. Zum Beispiel eben auch Provider anordnen, infizierte Kisten zu patchen aus der Ferne usw. Und dann hatte man damals aber auch eine ganze Menge andere Sachen mit reingepackt, die gerade so opportun waren. Das heißt, das war so kurz nach diesen Doxing-Vorfällen aus dem Januar 2019, da waren dann auch noch Strafrechtsverschärfungen drin und dann gab es dann...
Jetzt musst du erklären, was die Doxing-Vorfälle im Januar 2019 sind.
Eine lange Geschichte? Ich muss sie ja nicht alleine erzählen. Aber genau, es gab ja diese Geschichte mit dem sogenannten Adventskalender, das so ein Schüler irgendwo aus Hessen angefangen hat, diverse personenbezogene Daten von Promis und PolitikerInnen zu veröffentlichen. Vor allem auf Twitter, das hat man dann ein bisschen spät gemerkt. Und dann war plötzlich Doxing ganz schlimm. Und dann musste man ja irgendwas dagegen tun. Und dann hat man sich gedacht, okay, schreiben wir auch noch in den Entwurf fürs IT-Sicherheitsgesetz 2.0 rein.
An dieser Stelle möchte ich sozusagen klarstellen, dass ich meine, dass der ironische Unterton meint, Doxing ist ganz schlimm, aber eben nicht erst zu dem Zeitpunkt schon immer. Und man hat es erst dann entdeckt, als es Politiker selber betroffen hat.
Ja, und man hat halt einfach mit einer... Also es wurde ja damals auch irgendwie gefordert, dass jetzt der Hackback eingeführt wird, weil ein Schüler aus Hessen auf Twitter Daten veröffentlicht hat, was einfach auch komplett absurd war.
Ein invasiver Eingriff auf fremde IT-Systeme im Rahmen der Notfallgefahrenabwehr heißt, dass BMI möchte, dass man, wenn ein fieser Mensch zum Beispiel Schüler, die noch bei Mama leben, und Daten veröffentlichen, die auf einem Server liegen, dass deutsche Behörden diesen Server hacken und die Daten unwiderruflich löschen, damit sie für immer aus dem Internet getilgt sind. Solche Visionen haben die dann gefahren und aufgrund dessen massiv vorangetrieben und gesagt, wir brauchen den Hackback, wir müssen diese Zugriffe und Eingriffe in Fremdsysteme haben, was verfassungsrechtlich absolut nicht akzeptabel oder okay ist.
Jetzt hört sich das an zu sagen, das war dann auch ein Thema im IT-Sicherheitsgesetz. Das hört sich für mich an wie ein bunter Blumenstrauß irgendwas mit Internet. Was war denn das eigentliche Ziel des IT-Sicherheitsgesetzes?
Man hat den Blumenstrauß auch verwelken lassen. Viele von den Sachen sind schon nicht mehr aufgetaucht. Es war eine Zeit, wo gar nichts passiert ist, wo wir uns auch schon gefragt haben, arbeitet da noch irgendjemand dran? Und dann musste es plötzlich ganz schnell gehen und vieles war rausgeflogen und andere Sachen waren wieder drin. Ich glaube, Honkar kann da am meisten zu diesen schönen kurzen Stellungnahmefristen erzählen.
Ja, genau. Das IT-SIG II, ihr hattet ja im März 2019 die erste Entwurfsfassung geliegt, 90 Seiten. Im Mai gab es dann ein Update, 73 Seiten nur noch. Da wurde auf einmal ganz viel verfassungs- nicht so ganz konform wieder rausgetilgt. Dann kam lange Zeit nichts, wie du erwähnt hast. Im November kam dann die dritte Fassung, die hatte wieder 92 Seiten. Und dann ging es Schlag auf Schlag. 19.11. 1.12. 9.12. 11.12. 16.12. Das ging wirklich hintereinander. Und die Seitenzahlen haben sich von 92 auf 108 und auf 119 hin und her geschoben. Also allein an den Seitenzahlen sieht man, wie viel das ist. Wir haben das mal im Rahmen der AG Critis historisch aufbereitet, die Timeline und alle Fassungen mit Seitenangabe und Datum im Blog der AG Critis verlinkt. Packen wir mal in die Show Notes. Aber es ist so gewesen, dass da in dieser ersten Phase wirklich Monate dazwischen lagen und einfach niemand nichts getan hat und fast zwei Jahre hat vergehen lassen. Und dann ist denen aufgefallen, oh shit, die Legislaturperiode ist bald um. Wir kriegen all diese krassen Gesetzpassagen nicht durch. Dann müssen wir das ein bisschen runter strippen, damit es nicht ganz so verfassungs- nicht konform ist. Und dann durchboxen. Und dann gab es da so Stellungnahmefristen an die Wirtschaftsverbände, wie gibt eine Rückmeldung innerhalb von wenigen Tagen. Und die letzte Fassung hatte dann unter 24 Stunden Rückmeldefrist. Da konnte irgendwie gar keiner mehr reagieren. Es haben trotzdem, ich glaube, 24 NGOs und Wirtschaftsverbände Stellungnahmen eingereicht. Teilweise hatten die nur eine Seite oder zwei, wo drin stand, ja gut, wir sind Betroffener Wirtschaftsverband. Wir haben keine Informationen bekommen, haben zufällig mitbekommen, dass hier gerade eine Frist läuft. Und wir wollten nur sagen, also grundsätzlich sind wir nicht so erpicht und da stehen ein paar krasse Dinge drin, die wollen wir nicht, aber eine vollständige Ausarbeitung können wir gar nicht liefern, weil wir wurden ja nicht mal informiert. Und wenn Verbände, die eher konservativ sind und ruhig so krasse Ansagen liefern, ist das schon hart. Es gab auch Verbände wie den Bitkom, die dann sehr deutlich formuliert haben, das ist also alles völlig inakzeptabel, wir wurden überhaupt nicht bei diesem Gesetz irgendwie beteiligt und berücksichtigt, diese kurzen, knappen Fristen sind absolut nicht würdigend, das kann alles nicht wahr sein. Gut, die AG Krittes, wir haben ja dann auch nochmal eine ausführliche Stellungnahme geschrieben, was da alles desolat ist. Hatte aber alle nicht gejuckt, die haben das alles im Vollprogramm durchgezogen. Und nachdem auf diese letzte Stellungnahme mit diesen wenigen Stunden Frist quasi keiner mehr groß was geschrieben hat, weil ging ja fast gar nicht mehr, haben sich Leute vom BMI sogar öffentlich hingestellt und gesagt, ja, das ist richtig toll geworden, weil wir haben dann auch am Ende gar keine Kritik mehr bekommen. Wir haben ja alles gelesen und ein paar Dinge geändert. Und jetzt sind alle glücklich. Und jetzt können wir auch in Ruhe das Ding verabschieden. Und alle haben sich angeguckt und dachten, wait, what? Aber okay. Und so ähnlich lief es dann auch in der Anhörung. Wie gesagt, alle sechs Sachverständigen haben das Gesetz quasi zerrissen. Selbst der Sachverständige von der CDU hat gesagt, verfassungskonform ist das alles vermutlich nicht. Das ist ein bisschen schwierig. Und dann hatte aber ein Mensch von der CDU, ich weiß nicht mehr, wer es war, mittendrin irgendwann noch so ein Kommentar abgerissen. Ja, aber ich muss uns auch mal auf die Schulter klopfen. Das ist doch ein tolles Gesetz geworden. Und wir haben ja auch viel Herausragendes da reingearbeitet. Und wir sind sehr zufrieden damit. Und als ich dann bei der Fragerunde dran war, habe ich gesagt, ja wissen Sie, wenn sechs Sachverständige Ihnen sagen, dass das alles nicht so prall ist, aber Sie diese Meinung immer noch vertreten, gut, dann stelle ich mir die Frage, wofür diese Anhörung. Weil irgendwie ist ja vornherein klar gewesen, dass das alles schick ist. Wir wollten über die Problemstellung reden, aber wenn alles gelobt wird, naja gut, dann ist anscheinend alles schick. Das war schon krude.
Aber da muss ich doch noch mal einen kleinen Schlenker machen, weil ich habe damals, es gab eine KI-Ankettkommission. Und da hat sich damals vor Veröffentlichung des Abschlussberichts jemand hingestellt, der da teil war, hat gesagt, den Abschlussbericht kann ich nicht mit unterzeichnen, das ist Quatsch. Und ich habe auch zum Staatstrojaner, der neulich verabschiedet worden ist, habe ich auch Dinge gemacht, wo auch jemand was ähnliches gesagt hat wie die Expertenkommission. Und zurückkehrend zu diesem Ding, wo du jetzt diese Geschichte erzählst, ist das generell so gewesen, also auch bei all diesen Themen, die jetzt unter die heutige Sendung fallen, dass die Experten immer sehr einig waren und dann die Regierung quasi gesagt hat, dass es uns doch egal?
Vielleicht nicht immer, aber sehr, sehr, sehr oft. Also die Kritik von der Opposition oder von Experten wurde weggewicht. Ich habe es auch mal so ein bisschen Wissenschaftsfeindlichkeit in der Cyberpolitik genannt, vergleichbar mit der Wissenschaftsfeindlichkeit in der Klimapolitik, weil man einfach irgendwie immer wieder so Sprüche hört. Anna hatte ja dieses Sicherheit durch Verschlüsselung, Sicherheit trotz Verschlüsselung und solche Statements, die einfach wehtun, wenn man Sicherheit macht. So IT Security werden da durch die Bank weg immer wieder gebetsmühlenartig durchgezogen. Wir brauchen Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Genau, wir suchen eine Nadel im Heuhaufen, werft noch mehr Heu drauf. Toller Plan. Also das macht alles keinen Sinn, wenn man darüber nachdenkt, aber es geht da offenbar nicht um Sinn, sondern um das Stillen von Durst, der Befugniserweiterung von Sicherheitsbehörden und die kriegen den Hals nicht voll.
Aber woran liegt das denn? Liegt das daran, dass das Berufspolitiker sind?
Das ist ja auch eine große Sichtweise. Wenn ich sozusagen konsortuelle Politik mache, dann gehe ich davon aus, ich stelle eine Regel auf und dann wird die auch eingehalten. Dann kann ich noch die Durchsetzung der Regeln forcieren. Aber ich habe erstmal keinerlei Ansinnen zu gucken, wie reagieren denn die Leute da draußen auf die Dinge, die ich tue? Und was sollte ich dann am besten darauf tun, damit ich die in eine bestimmte Richtung bewege? Also sozusagen diese Führung der Politik, wir bestimmen, was hier Sache ist, spiegelt sich dann auch in den Anhörungen wider. Üblicherweise ist aber auch so, dass so Wirtschaftsverbände selten neue Befugnisnormen für Geheimdienste oder für die Polizei kritisieren, sondern die kritisieren in der Regel dann Punkte, wenn es die irgendwie Geld kostet, und sie Dinge umsetzen müssen. Das heißt, in der Regel kriegen die nicht allzu viel Gegenwind von Wirtschaftsverbänden, sondern nur von der Zivilgesellschaft oder von der Opposition.
Na, aber das ist ja in dem Fall ja passiert. Und dann muss man ja, also jetzt mal, obwohl wir noch nicht am Ende sind von dem IT-Sicherheitsgesetz, aber schon mal fragen. Dann ist ja bei der nächsten Bundestagswahl vielleicht nicht nur die Frage, wähle ich jemanden, der meinen politischen Einstellungen entspricht, sondern vielleicht auch mal wähle ich jemanden, der auf die Experten hört, ExpertInnen hört. Und dann ist die Frage, gibt es so jemand?
Ich meine, sie haben sich ja auch an verschiedenen Stellen noch ExpertInnen und ähnliche Dinge eingekauft. Es gab zum Beispiel noch als Spin-off zu dieser Huawei-Debatte auch noch diese Debatte rund um digitale Souveränität, wo dann am Ende auch noch so eine Sprung-Agentur herausgekommen ist. Und die fördert ja jetzt momentan so...
Schau, schau, schau, wir können erst mal bei der Frage bleiben. Also die Frage ist die, also momentan sind CDU und SPD an der Macht. Wenn ich jetzt eine von den anderen im Bundestag vertretenen demokratischen Parteien wähle, habe ich dann Aussicht, also Gesetze, die kommen in die Macht, versteht sich, habe ich dann eine Aussicht, dass wenn die den Sachverständigen einladen und der sagt, nee, das ist Quatsch, dass sie dann auch darauf hören. Also diese Wissenschaftsfeindlichkeit, was Honka gerade meinte. Sind die alle so, ist Politik momentan gerade so oder kann meine Wahlentscheidung auch beeinflussen? Nicht mal inhaltlich, wo es langgeht, sondern einfach nur, dass auf ExpertInnen gehört wird.
Also ich glaube so schwarz-weiß einfach ist es nicht. Ich gebe mal nur ein paar Beispiele, die ich ganz persönlich und nur ganz eingeschränkt sagen kann. Saskia Esken persönlich hat eine Meinung und eine Vorstellung, die ist sehr, sehr kompatibel mit meiner. Allerdings gibt es in der Partei, in der SPD, offenbar viele, die ganz andere Vorstellungen haben. Und dann kann sie alleine auch nicht viel bewirken. Aber das ist schon mal innerhalb der Partei ein Unterschied. Es gibt auch den Sebastian Hartmann, hieß er, glaube ich, von der SPD. Der ist auch ganz fähig, was Katastrophenschutz und so angeht. Aber an anderen Stellen teile ich vieles von der SPD nicht, weil sie halt jedes Mal umgekippt ist. Wenn die CDU sagt, hü, wer sehr positiv hervorsticht, ist zum Beispiel die Anke Domscheit-Berg von den Linken auch. Wir haben aber auch, um nochmal bei der SPD ein Beispiel zu nennen, die Frau Elvan Korkmaz-Emre, die stellvertretende Digitalsprecherin, glaube ich, auch sehr interessante und fähige Meinung. Es gibt auch bei den Grünen einige, die da sehr geschickt und sehr zugehörend agieren. Es ist ein bunter Blumenstrauß von teilweise Partei, aber ganz oft tatsächlich Einzelpersonen, die sie hervorstechen und auch zuhören, wenn Menschen Kritik äußern und sagen, ich hinterfrag die Kritik und komme auf den Punkt dahinter. Tatsächlich ist diese Schnittmenge sehr niedrig mit der CDU-CSU. Das kann man nicht pauschalisieren.
Als Wähler muss ich das. Lass mich versuchen, nochmal die Frage zu stellen. Am Beispiel SPD weiß ich, möglicherweise gibt es da gute Leute. Aber wenn wieder so eine Situation kommt, wie gerade beschrieben, wo alle Expertinnen sagen, das ist Quatsch, dann sagt die Partei trotzdem, das ist uns egal. Und das ist die Frage, die ich stelle. Mal abgesehen davon, dass bei der SPD die, die, sagen wir mal, kaosnahen Positionen, um mal ganz vorsichtig zu sein, vertreten, eher unter der Kategorie Ausnahmen bestätigen, die Regeln sind. Ähm, gibt es andere Parteien, wo ich mich darauf verlassen kann, dass die machen, was die Expertinnen sagen? Und wie gesagt, erst mal egal, ob das jetzt meine, deine, unsere politische Richtung ist, sondern einfach, die darauf hören, was Expertinnen sagen. Das ist die Frage.
Ich glaube, das können wir nicht wissen.
Das ist tatsächlich wie, haben gerade gesagt, das ist nicht so schwarz und weiß, sondern du hast ja durchaus sozusagen auch in einer Partei eine gewisse Bandbreite an Personen. Ja, und wir kennen jetzt die Netzpolitiker, die thematisch in der Regel rechtlich beieinanderstehen. Ob das jetzt irgendwie von Notz ist, von den Grünen oder Manuel von der FDP oder auch die Linke mit der Anker Domscheit-Berg, die sind ja doch immer recht einig im Ausschuss für die Digital Agenda. Zeitlich hast du aber auch die Parteien, die auf Länderebene öfter mal andere Dinge gemacht haben. Zum Beispiel der erste Staatstrial, den wir bekommen haben, der kam aus NRW mit einem FDP-Innenminister. Wir haben auch diverse Bundesländer, wo die Grünen mitregieren, wo es dann für die Polizei oder für den Verfassungsschutz Hackback-Paragrafen gab. Also es ist sozusagen dort immer eine Sache der Koalition. Ich glaube erst aus der Koalition heraus bildet sich die Gesamtposition. Und dann ist sozusagen die Meinung der Experten ja auch immer vielfältig. Kommt doch immer an, wen man als Experte einlädt.
Stopp, das hört sich gerade nicht so an. Hongas hat gerade gesagt, alle Experten, auch der von der CU, waren sich einig, die haben es trotzdem gemacht. Das ist der Fall, über den ich rede.
Das ist selten, weil in der Regel findet man ja einen Experten, der die gleiche Meinung vertritt, wie man selbst. Also wenn man sozusagen eine Anhörung macht, dann lehrt man ja schon Experten ein, die Meinung vertreten, die man gerne hören möchte.
Und das hat die CDU nicht geschafft beim IT-Sicherheitsgesetz 2. So schlimm ist das Ding, ja?
Also alles, was ihr sagt, ich verstehe das. Ich verstehe natürlich sozusagen den Bedarf, das nicht aufs Weiß zu sehen, aber das heißt für mich auch, daran kann ich meine Wahlentscheidung nicht festmachen?
Nee, kann man nicht. Weil die Parteien agieren unterschiedlich, weil die Leute unterschiedlich agieren. Oder der, ich sag mal, Kompromiss- und Q-Handel, der dann manchmal gemacht wird, unterschiedlich ist.
Vielleicht müssen wir doch alles anzünden.
Ich glaube, es ist nicht nur das.
Ich bin dabei.
Wenn die Anhörung gemacht wird, dann hat sich die GroKo schon geeinigt zwischen den Ministerien. Dann wird selten noch mal im Parlament ein großes Fass aufgemacht.
Ja, ich glaube, es ist auch das Problem nicht so sehr bei dem IT-Sicherheitsgesetz, sondern vor allem bei so Gesetzen, die mehr Befugnisse für Strafverfolgungsbehörden und Co. bringen, dass die ja oft so ereignisgetrieben sind. Oder auch beim Anfang des IT-Sicherheitsgesetzes die Geschichte mit dem Doxing-Fall. Das war ja eine Reaktion. Ich glaube, da setzt bei vielen in Regierungsverantwortung dieses Auf-Experten-Hören irgendwie aus. Weil wenn ich jetzt der Expertin bin, dann bin ich vielleicht nicht so ereignisgetrieben von wegen, es gab jetzt einen Doxing-Fall, der aufsehenerregt hat, sondern bin eher auf die lange Sicht getrieben. Aber wenn ich natürlich in dieser Tagespolitik stecke und reagieren muss und demonstrieren muss, dass ich reagieren kann, dann ist auch die Tendenz schnell vielleicht nicht ganz so langfristig gut überlegte Reaktionen zu fahren. Und ich glaube, das ist auch das, was generell fehlt, eben zu sagen, Cybersicherheit ist oder IT-Sicherheit ist, nicht nur irgendwie ein Reagieren auf irgendwelche gerade stattfindenden Huawei-Debatten oder sonstige Dinge, sondern eigentlich was Langfristigeres. Aber mit was Langfristigerem kann man halt nicht eine Legislaturperiode bestreiten, weil die dauert halt nicht so lang. Und das ist auch das, woran es glaube ich oft krankt.
Es ist ja auch so, das ein Gesetz zu machen und eine Strafverschärfung einzuführen recht einfach ist. Das kostet wenig Geld, ist schnell gemacht. Man kann zeigen, dass man gehandelt hat. Und muss sich dann nicht um die tatsächlichen Probleme kümmern und langfristige Lösungen finden.
Ich kriege hier langsam Kopfschmerzen, Leute.
Das ist leider so.
Ja, aber ich mein, also in meiner naiven Idee dachte ich, dass ihr erklärt, wie man es besser, also wie es besser werden kann. Nicht, dass man eigentlich das Ganze, egal, ich wollte gerade schon wieder anzünden. Anyway, IT-Sicherheitsgesetz. Was ist denn da jetzt bei rausgekommen? Ist da jetzt bei etwas rausgekommen, wo man bei der nächsten Bundestagswahl jemanden wählen muss, der sagt, das schaffen wir auf jeden Fall wieder ab? Oder ist es jetzt so, naja, super geil, das ist nicht gelaufen, aber ist schon okay?
Da wirst du nichts abschaffen. Mit dem Elend, was man da fabriziert hat, wird die Wirtschaft und die kritischen Infrastrukturen und die digitalen Verbrauchsschurznummern, die da rein integriert wurden, in den nächsten Jahren bzw. bei kritischen Infrastrukturen in den Jahrzehnten, diese ganze Müll, sozusagen eine IT-Unsicherheit schaffen. Das ist jetzt eingemauert. Der Drops ist gelutscht.
Man kann schon sehen, dass das in den nächsten vier Jahren nach der Wahl nochmal angepasst wird oder verändert wird.
Ich würde ein IT-Sicherheitsgesetz 3 geben, was man anpassen muss. Aber das wird ja nicht verbessert.
Jungs, Butter bei die Fische.
Da steht zum Beispiel drin, digitaler Verbraucherschutz. Wir haben jetzt ein freiwilliges IT-Sicherheitskennzeichen für Consumer-Produkte. Juhu. Freiwillig auf Hersteller-Selbstauskunft. Das klingt jetzt nicht nach Erhöhung der IT-Sicherheit. Da steht drin diese Lex-Hua-Wai-Klausel. Da haben wir gerade drüber gesprochen. Wenn du kritischer Infrastruktur bist, dann musst du ein Angriffserkennungssystem installieren und betreiben. Punkt. Vorher stand da drin, du musst den Stand der Technik braunespezifisch und angemessen betreiben. Jetzt musst du auf einmal gewaltsam ein Angriffserkennungssystem installieren. Welcher Lobby ist das hingekriegt, diesen Quark da reinzuschreiben? Der hat auf jeden Fall einen Schampus aufgemacht an dem Abend. Das schreibst du nicht vor, sondern du entscheidest anhand deiner Risikolage und Bewertung deiner Infrastruktur, ob du ein solches System einführst. Nur, bevor du das einführst, machst du Firewall-Regel-Updates, du führst ein Logging ein, du guckst sogar in die Logfiles rein, du hast eine Alarmkette und alles das. So diese absoluten Basics machen die meisten kritischen Infrastrukturen nicht mal Stand heute. Fernzugriff oder Fernwartung auch nicht. Völlig desolat an ganz vielen Stellen.
Und du sagst das jetzt, weil das alles nicht drinsteht?
Na ja, das steht alles nicht. Na ja, das stand vorher drin, das steht drin. Du musst einen Stand der Technik erfüllen. Heißt, du nimmst sowas wie ISO 27001, BCAT Grundschutz oder, oder, oder.
Wenn du so weitermachst, frage ich dich, was das genau bedeutet.
Du machst einen Sicherheitsstandard, befolgst du und setzt ein Informationssicherheitsmanagementsystem um. Du hast Prozesse, mit denen du IT sinnvoll betreibst. Was sie aber vorgegriffen haben, ist jetzt, ja, ja, das machst du, aber das Angriffserkennungssystem musst du auf jeden Fall sofort gesetzliche Auflage installieren. Und dann gehen die kritischen Infrastrukturbetreiber nicht hin und sagen, risikobasiert mache ich sinnvolle Dinge der Reihe nach. Sondern, also erstmal habe ich ein Gesetz erfüllen, ich installiere diese Dinge. Wie viel Restgeld haben wir noch an Budget? Okay, der Rest muss ein bisschen leiden. Das ist hanebüchener Unsinn. Dazu hat man noch erfunden im IT-Sicherheitsgesetz II, die Unbüfi-Unternehmen in besonderem öffentlichen Interesse. Das ist dreistufig. Es gibt besonders wirtschaftlich große, wichtige Unternehmen. Die brauchen Sicherheitskonzept, aber keine externe Prüfung. Also diese Unbüfi sind so nahe das Kritische Leid, nicht ganz und nicht halb so. Die machen irgendwie ein Sicherheitskonzept und dann reicht das auch. Das sind jetzt irgendwie große wirtschaftliche Unternehmen in Deutschland, also Automobilindustrie und ein paar andere. Da kann man schon sagen, aha, das erhöht jetzt die IT-Sicherheit in Deutschland, ja irgendwie unklar. Der zweite Teil der Unbüfis sind Waffenhersteller und Rüstungsindustrie, wo ich dann denke, ach, die will man nicht aus der nationalen Sicherheitsperspektive betrachten und vielleicht aus anderen Gründen viel sicherer mit höheren Auflagen. Okay, dann hat man die hier drunter gefuscht, ist günstig. Verstehe ich auch nicht. Der dritte Teil sind alle, die unter die Gefahrgutverordnung fallen. Die sind jetzt irgendwie so, naja, auch kritisch leid. Man könnte auch einfach die Frage stellen, das Bundesamt für Bevölkerungsschutz und Katastrophenhilfe, also BBK hat vor vielen, vielen Jahren schon gesagt, nur diesen Punkt noch zu Ende führen als Beispiel. Sektor Chemie und Sektor Großforschungseinrichtungen könnte man ja als kritische Infrastruktur definieren. Und da wurde aber lobbyistisch gegengewirkt und gesagt, naja, dann machen wir jetzt dieses Gefahrgut als unbüffige Kripsel. Das ist alles nichts Ganzes und nichts Halbes. Und so sieht dieses IT-Sicherheitsgesetz 2.0 an ganz vielen Stellen aus.
Ich würde noch ergänzen wollen, das hat ja auch positive Aspekte. Erstmals dafür ist das BSI verbindlich festlegen, welche Mindeststandards für die Bundesbehörden gelten. Heißt, sie können tatsächlich festlegen, was jetzt quasi gemacht werden muss. Zum Beispiel Webseiten müssen HTTPS haben oder solche Geschichten könnten sie jetzt festlegen, wenn sie wollten. Und das schafft ja auf Seiten der Verwaltung schon mal ein bisschen mehr Sicherheit.
Und ich würde auch noch mal eine positive Vision aufmachen. Ich glaube, wir kriegen vieles, was da drin steht, jetzt nicht mehr sofort weg. Aber vielleicht kann man ja einige der Sachen, die da drin fehlen, einfach auch in den nächsten Jahren mal angehen. Weil das finde ich nämlich teilweise fast noch schlimmer, als das, was drin steht, als das, was eben nicht drin steht. Ich glaube, ein ähnlich langer Prozess wie das IT-Sicherheitsgesetz ist dieses sogenannte Schwachstellenmanagement, das man mal auf die Kette kriegen sollte. Sprich, irgendwie sich zu überlegen, wie geht denn der Staat zum Beispiel mit gefundenen Schwachstellen um? Und da gibt es, obwohl die Diskussion seit Jahren läuft, immer noch kein Ergebnis, obwohl wir die dringend mal bräuchten, weil das eben in allen möglichen Bereichen immer wieder vorkommt. Und da würde ich einfach mal hoffen, dass wir vielleicht mitfähigen, Leuten dazu mal... Ich habe keine große Hoffnung, aber zumindest sehe ich, dass man da noch was tun kann.
Auch auf die Gefahren, dass ich die Frage bereuen werde. Entnehme ich deinen Worten, dass, wenn der Staat eine Sicherheitslücke findet, hat er sie gefälligst so schnell wie möglich zu schließen, nicht aktueller Stand der Politik und der Gesetzgebung ist?
Ja, aber dann kann man sie nicht ausnutzen selber. Manchmal will der Staat Sicherheitslücken ausnutzen, um zum Beispiel Staatsdruyaner und so weiter und so fort. Dann ist es nicht im Interesse des Staates, die Sicherheitslücke zu schließen.
Oh Gott, gibt es an dem Wahlprogramm irgendwas? Ja, vieles. Kann ich Parteien oder eine Partei wählen, die sagt, das ist totaler Quatsch, Sicherheitslücken werden geschlossen, weil es die Aufgabe, weil es die grundgesetzlich verankerte Fürsorgepflicht des Staates ist, Menschen zu schützen.
Ja, das steht glaube ich in der Mehrheit der Programme drin.
Nee, tatsächlich nicht so, oder? Also so explizit nicht.
Ich meine, ich habe es bei den Grünen, bei der FDP und bei der Linken gesehen.
Genau.
Bei der SPD weiß ich es gerade nicht.
Ja, die SPD sagt doch tatsächlich, die SPD sagt, Hintertüren sollen nicht offen gehalten werden, das sagen sie.
Die SPD, die gerade das Gesetz mit beschlossen hat. Ich frage nur.
Also man kann ja durchaus sozusagen im Wahlprogramm das reinschreiben, was man gerne möchte. Und dann sieht man, was man halt mit dem Koalitionspartner, mit der CDU so machen kann. Das sind teils so verschiedene Dinge.
Was in einer bis zur letzten Entwurfsfassung vor der letzten Änderung und anschließend Absegnung des IT-Sicherheitsgesetzes 2 drin stand, war, im Falle des Falles, wenn Dinge aus Gründen wichtig sind für den Staat, dann hat das BSI gefunden, Lücken zurückzuhalten und weiterzureichen. Da haben wirklich alle ganz laut geschrien und gesagt, ihr wollt jetzt irgendwie den BSI anordnen, dass es Sicherheitslücken zurückhalten muss und den Sicherheitsbehörden bereitstellt. Dass es nicht unabhängig ist, haben wir ja schon gelernt. Aber das ist jetzt wirklich der Genickbruch. Und diesen Passus haben sie dann zähneknirschend gestrichen. Aber der Versuch, das sozusagen richtig zu verankern, dass das BSI Schwachstellen zurückhalten muss, um sie für die staatlichen Akteure bereitzustellen, der war schon im IT-Sicherheitsgesetz zwei in den Entwürfen drin.
Hab ich schon alles anzünden? Ich hab schon alles anzünden gesagt. Ich glaube, damit... Ja, also das heißt, diese IT-Sicherheitsgesetznummer können wir abschließen. Also da steht viel Unsinn drin, ein klein wenig Positives. Manche Sachen wurden noch gar nicht besprochen. Die könnte man noch klären. Tut euch wahrscheinlich schwer mit konkreten Wahlempfehlungen, aber lasst es mich andersrum fragen. Wenn ich möchte, dass sich die Situation in diesem Bereich besser hat, will ich dann nochmal die GroKo?
Also ich meine, die hatten jetzt viele Jahre und wenn man die CDU anguckt, 16 Jahre die Möglichkeit, was ins Positive zu ändern. Und guck mal 16 Jahre zurück, was genau ist denn da wirklich besser geworden und wie viel ist schlimmer geworden. Die haben Digitalisierung null verstanden, den ganzen Zeitraum nicht kapiert und versuchen an irgendwelchen alten Machtstrukturen und Fründen festzutackern, dass es nicht Digitalisierung, wie man sie bräuchte oder versteht. Sorry.
Wie ist denn das mit der SPD? Also die hat, also persönlich kann ich, ach ich sag, lass das lieber raus. Also die hat ja, die hat ja sozusagen, habt ihr gesagt, die hat manchmal gute Ideen und es gibt einzelne Stimmen, die vernünftig klingen und dann fällt sie immer sozusagen mit dem, dann wirft jemand mit dem Koalitionsvertrag nach der SPD und dann fällt sie um. Jetzt ist die Frage, es ist ja theoretisch denkbar, die SPD käme mit jemand anderes als der Union in der GroKo. Habt ihr den Eindruck, dass dann auch Dinge da anders laufen würden oder dass dann Law & Order, ich meine, irgendwie Olaf Scholz als, also G20 Olaf Scholz als Kanzlerkandidat, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ist die SPD sehr weit entfernt von dem, was die Union da macht?
Es gibt gleich immer einen Konflikt zwischen den netzpolitisch aktiven Politikerinnen und dem Bereich Innenpolitik. Das ist gleich bei wenigen Parteien überschnitten. Also ich glaube, den gibt bei der SPD jemanden, der sozusagen im Innenausschuss ist und auch im ADER und auch bei den Grünen gab es ja den Frau Notz, der dann im Innenbereich gewechselt ist. Aber üblicherweise hat man im Innenbereich eher die Hardliner, die jetzt sagen, VDS fordern und Stroyana und andere Geschichten.
Ja, wobei ich sagen würde...
Wie sehr sich dann auch diese Netzszene durchsetzen kann.
Ich würde sagen, wenn die SPD mit wem anders regieren würde, hätte ich eine Hoffnung, dass es vielleicht keinen Hackback gibt in der nächsten Legislatur. Ich glaube, wenn die SPD wieder mit der CDU reagiert, dann ist das Thema durch und dann haben wir verloren. Ich glaube, das wäre vielleicht so eine rote Linie, die ich hoffen würde, dass die SPD sie noch hält. Aber ganz sicher, Lokalgravitation ist es schwierig, wenn man umfallen will.
Das heißt, die SPD ist auf jeden Fall eine Partei, wo es diese beiden Lager gibt und wo man vorher nicht genau ausmachen kann, wer da am längeren hebelt. Das heißt, einerseits, man kann also nicht sicher sein, ob da nicht irgendein Quatsch passiert. Das heißt, andererseits, aber doch, und das hätte ich gerne noch mal explizit bestätigt, es gibt auch die Möglichkeit, dass es gut läuft.
Oder dass es nicht noch schlimmer wird.
Vielleicht macht auch jemand mal einen Antrag, den Neckback wieder zu löschen und die VDS endlich mal liegen zu lassen und abzuschaffen. Weil die ist ja immer noch in so einem Nichtanwendungsbereich, aber eigentlich immer noch gesetzt. Und es gibt ja auch jetzt immer wieder Forderungen, die nochmal neu aufzuwärmen und im Rahmen der E-Privacy-Verordnung Regelungen zu schaffen für die VDS. Auch das Thema Beweissicherung, weil noch so ein Thema mit der E-Evidence-Verordnung, also wie kann ich bei Clouddiensten Daten sichern oder Beweis sichern oder Beschlagnahmen. Das sind ja noch alles Felder, die jetzt auch europäisch aufgerollt werden, wo aber auch die Position der Bundesregierung natürlich maßgeblich wird, wie dann quasi solche Regelungen ausgestattet werden.
Wie ist es denn bei FDP, Grünen, Linken? Ist es da auch so sagen bei allen Parteien so? Es gibt die innere Sicherheit-Hardliner, es gibt die netzpolitischen Menschen keine Überwachung und die streiten sich dann fröhlich, man weiß nicht so genau. Oder gibt es irgendeine Partei, die da eine netzpolitisch klare Ausrichtung in Richtung wir wollen, dass Verschlüsselung funktioniert, wir wollen, dass so wenig wie möglich überwacht wird, Punkt. Wir wollen, dass sich jetzt Lücken geschlossen werden.
Also ich glaube, bei allen drei Parteien gibt es klare Beschlusslagen gegen Trojaner und für die Sicherheit von Verschlüsselung und gegen das Ausnutzen von Sicherheitslücken. Natürlich wirst du in jeder Partei auch Personen finden, die das Gegenteil fordern, aber Beschlusslage ist in all drei Parteien sozusagen die Ablehnung von Trojanern und die Ausbildung der alten Sicherheit.
Haltet ihr das für glaubwürdig?
Dass sie das Ziel haben?
Ja, aber ich denke halt auch, ihr könnt ja nicht meine Wahlentscheidungen allein auf diesem Thema aufbauen.
Das habe ich versucht, um einfach zu erklären. Wir machen hier heute nicht alles. Wir machen heute exakt dieses Thema. Das ist der Punkt. Deswegen will ich nur wissen, wenn man diese Sendung gehört hat, dann weiß man vielleicht, hat man eine grobe Idee, wo stehen die einzelnen Parteien bei diesem Thema. Die Wahlentscheidung ist dann noch mal was ganz anderes. Aber es ist ja, erkennt ihr vielleicht auch an meinen verzweifelten Fragen, es ist ja schon schwierig überhaupt zu entscheiden, wenn dieses eine Thema für mich doch wichtig ist. Es gibt ja bestimmt Leute, für die ist das Digitale eher so, meine Güte, ist mir egal. Wir sind andere Themen viel wichtiger. Förderung des öffentlichen Nahverkehrs oder Bildung oder was auch immer. Das kann ja alles sein. Die Sendung heute ist für die Leute, die das zu einem Teil, das ist mir wichtig, ihrer Wahlentscheidung machen wollen. Das ist nicht, dass wir sagen, wenn ich euch jetzt frage, die Frage, die ich gerade gestellt habe, FDP, Grüne, Linke, wie sieht es da aus, heißt das nicht, wenn die da das Richtige machen, sollte die unbedingt wählen, sondern der eine Teil des Bausteins in eurer Entscheidung. Liebe Hörerinnen, ich spreche jetzt gerade zu euch, die Wahlentscheidung zu treffen, könnte dann so ausfallen. Also ich möchte euch, liebe Gäste, überhaupt gar nicht in die Verlegenheit bringen, dass irgendjemand sagt, aber die haben gesagt, er soll den und den wählen, das nicht. Es geht um eine expertige Einschätzung des politischen Vorgehens für die Leute, die eben nicht wie ihr die letzten vier Jahre und teilweise noch sehr viel länger auf dem Thema drauf sitzen, die sozusagen die Sache einfach überblicken können und eine Einschätzung geben können. Das ist tatsächlich alles, was ich will. Ich möchte niemanden diese Verantwortung aufdrücken. So, gut, so viel dazu. Jetzt bin ich bei einem, ich habe vorhin sozusagen den Versuch einer Abzweigung unterbunden, zu dem ich jetzt gerne zurückkehren würde. Agentur für Sprung Innovation hat jemand gesagt. Was ist das? Was ist da passiert? Und wie beeinflusst es die Diskussion heute? Ich glaube, Markus hat damit angefangen.
Ja, also es gab da sozusagen die Idee, wir hängen ein bisschen hinterher. Und China und die USA sind ganz weit vorne bei irgendwas, innovativen. Und deswegen müssen wir jetzt quasi sehr viel Geld ausgeben, um aufzuholen. So ein bisschen wie früher im Kalten Krieg das Wetteristen. Wir müssen ein bisschen aufholen. Und dazu wollen wir eine Sprung Innovation machen. Und da hat man zwei Agenturen gegründet. Eine für zivile Innovation und eine für Innovation in der Cybersicherheit, die ADIC. Und da gab es dann sowohl das Projekt GaiaX, wo sich quasi Open Source Befürworter versammelt haben und dann der Regierung im Rahmen von diesem digitalen Severänitätsdebatten verkauft haben, dass man doch jetzt ein europäisches, sicheres Open Source Cloud System bauen müsste, damit man hier in Europa sicher und souverän Cloud-Dienste betreiben kann. Und das ist jetzt mal was, das man so zum Teil gut finden kann und zum Teil auch schwierig findet. Ich finde den Open Source Teil gut. Über das Setting und die Art und Weise, wie es gemacht wird, kann man vielleicht darüber reden, aber im Prinzip fand ich, dass man einen positiven Aspekt des Open Source da, wenn auch mit einer komischen Begründung, eine Förderung erhält.
Das andere Ding ist, wenn man jetzt Cloud sagt, wäre jetzt mein Verdacht, dass es eigentlich nicht die clevere Idee ist, einen weiteren zentralen Service zu machen, sondern dass man eher eine Technologie entwickeln wollen würde, die diese Technologie Leuten zur Verfügung stellt, die diese dann selber betreiben können, oder in Genossenschaften oder sowas?
Ja, die Idee ist quasi, dass wir die verschiedenen Rechenzentren in Europa so einen gemeinsamen Stack anbieten, dass du halt auch zwischen verschiedenen Rechenzentren deine Services verschieben kannst, dass du halt diese vielen kleinen Anbieter in Europa zu einem größeren virtuellen Service zusammenbilden kannst.
Und heißt das, diese Agentur ist sozusagen eine sinnvolle Einrichtung gewesen oder eher sehr viel heiße Luft um nichts?
Naja, ich finde halt so Agenturen in Form einer GmbH immer schwierig, weil es halt so eine Art Schattenhaushalt wird. Du steckst halt viel Geld rein, hast aber keine öffentliche Kontrolle darüber, was damit passiert. Und als Staat sollte man schon dafür sorgen, dass wir eine maschinenläsbare Regierung haben, eine alte Chaos-Forderung und das heißt halt auch ein offener Haushalt.
Ich würde noch ein consumerorientiertes Thema, eine consumerorientierte Frage stellen wollen. Auch auf die Gefahren, dass ich vielleicht sage, das hat gar nichts damit zu tun, aber irgendwie doch. Und zwar kommt der Gedanke daraus, es gab neulich, was war denn, Osram. Osram hatte glaube ich so ein Home-Automation-Dings. Und da schalten sie jetzt die Server ab, und wenn man sich nicht rechtzeitig kümmert, hat man dann Glühlampen, die nicht mehr funktionieren. Und diese ganze Diskussion hat mich auf die Idee gebracht, dass das gibt es ja auch, also ein Teil von Cyber-Sicherheit ist ja auch die Sicherheit meiner privaten Infrastruktur. Da gibt es immer diese Frage, dürfen Leute oder Firmen ihre Router irgendwie zumachen, dass da gar keine mehr Kontrolle drüber hat? Kann man die verpflichten, dass sie irgendwie wenigstens x Jahre nach verkauft, dass sie der Patches nachreichen müssen? Und diese ganzen Sachen eher so, was ganz sehr kleines, frickeliges, detailhaftes, was aber glaube ich im einzelnen Leben immer wichtig ist. Ist das auch überhaupt ein Thema gewesen, so was? Oder fällt das für euch da ganz raus? Oder lohnt gar nicht, weil es zu kleinteilig ist?
Nö, es ist ein wichtiges Thema und ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wer vom CCC, aber in einer Anhörung hatte angebracht, dass man bei Software durchaus mal nachdenken sollte, um ein Mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum einzuführen, damit es einfach auch eine garantierte Zeit gibt, in der ich weiß, die ist funktional und kann sicher betrieben werden. Spätestens, wenn du in Richtung kritische Infrastrukturen abbiegst, wird es unheimlich schwer, weil die teilweise Komponenten einsetzen, die Jahrzehnte betrieben werden. Und wenn du dann Mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum von zwei oder fünf Jahren hast, dann lachen die einmal herzlich. Ein Flugzeug ab Design bis zur Stilllegung des letzten Fliegers kann 50 Jahre in Anspruch nehmen. Damit erstegst du auch nicht alles, aber zumindest für Konsumer, so wie du gerade angesprochen hast, könnte man mit so einem Mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum schon viel erreichen, dass die Firmen da eben nicht nur auf die Wirtschaftlichkeit gucken, sondern sagen, na gut, dann müssen wir doch in sichere Softwareentwicklung mal ein bisschen mehr investieren. Denn die Abläufe und die Prozesse, wie man sichere Software entwickelt, Secure by Design, Secure by Default und so, gibt es alles. Das ist alles vorhanden, aber es wird selten ordentlich umgesetzt, weil eben keine Notwendigkeit da ist.
Es gab jetzt auch eine EU-Richtlinie zu dem Thema, zum Thema digitale Produkte und Kauf von digitalen Inhalten und Dienstleistungen. Das ist auch in ein Gesetz umgewandelt worden. Und ich glaube, ab 2022 bekommen dann Verbraucherinnen mehr Rechte. Es gibt auch zum Teil eine Updatepflicht für Unternehmen, dass sie ihre Produkte halt im Rahmen einer gewissen Frist, die sie sich selber setzen können, dann quasi mit funktionserhaltenden Updates versorgen. Das ist aber eine relativ neue Regelung. Daher gibt es vielleicht noch nicht viel, was die Implementierung angeht oder die Umsetzung.
Und die Regelung, die bezieht sich nur auf Software oder Dienstleistungsprodukte?
Auf digitale Produkte. Es gibt verschiedene Kategorien von Produkten. Ob ich jetzt ein E-Book kaufe oder ob ich digitales Fernsehen mir einkaufe oder Video-and-Demand-Dienste oder ob ich mir quasi ein intelligentes Glühbirnsystem hole. Da gibt es verschiedene Kategorien, die dann verschiedene Service Level erfüllen müssen.
Das heißt sozusagen, das ist eine gute Idee, die aber noch nicht explizit genug ist?
Hab ich das richtig verstanden? Es gibt dazu jetzt ein Gesetz, das ist halt neu. Es tritt dann nächstes Jahr an Kraft. Wir können das ja nachher mal verlinken in den Show Notes. Aber zu den genauen Regeln kann ich jetzt auch nicht so viel sagen. Ich hatte das mal gelesen, aber das ist schon eine Weile her.
Okay. Haben die anderen beiden da noch irgendwie zu dem Ding, oder was in dem Wahlprogramm steht? Wisst ihr da noch, was vielleicht?
Ich glaube, die Linke hat sich tatsächlich explizit reingeschrieben, so Produkthaftung für Hersteller auszuweiten. Bei den anderen habe ich gerade gar nicht so den Überblick, aber ich glaube einfach, es ist ein unglaublich wichtiges Thema, weil ansonsten ja Personen einfach... Doch die FDP hat sich es auch reingeschrieben. Und ich glaube, es ist eben nicht so kleinteilig, sondern schon eines der wichtigeren Themen, weil ich glaube, dadurch, dass Hersteller eben wissen, dass sie im Zweifelsfall zur Verantwortung gezogen werden können, müssen sie ja auch ihre Prozesse umstellen, eben hin zu einer IT-Sicherheit, die nicht irgendwie nachträglich so ein bisschen sorgenkindmäßig draufgepfropft wird, sondern so, dass es sich dann eben, dass es eben auch für die Hersteller im Nachhinein nicht schmerzhaft wird, wenn sie dann eben haften müssen. Und ich glaube, das kann einfach auch ein bisschen so die ganze Produktionsmoral ein bisschen umdrehen im besten Fall. Und das hilft ja dann nicht nur den Leuten, die dann sich eine Glühbirne installieren, sondern auch vielen anderen.
Das ist eh dann ein Thema, wo wir jetzt gefühlt sozusagen so ein bisschen hinsteuern. Weil ich habe den Eindruck, wann immer man was Konkretes fragt, ist so, kann man sagen, was in den letzten Jahren gelaufen wird, fällt dann unter die Kategorie, fällt bestenfalls unter die Kategorie, es ist nicht vollständig kaputt. Aber ist dann irgendwie kompliziert. Können wir vielleicht eine Ebene größer gehen und sagen, also die deutsche, nicht nur Cyber-Sicherheitspolitik, sondern Digitalpolitik wirkt auf mich immer wie so ein Hinterherrennen. Also andere Länder sind weiter, wenn man das schon hört. Oder wir brauchen mehr Sicherheit. Das heißt, es scheint so gar nicht so ein langfristiges zu geben sein. Es gibt immer nur so ein Gepätsche. Gibt es mittlerweile in der Politik, wo man sagen kann, naja, das Konkreteste ist der eine, aber die haben wenigstens langfristig eine Perspektive, wo es hingehen kann? Also die wissen überhaupt, was man machen muss? Oder bleibt das bei allen politischen Kräften in diesem kleinen Kleinen?
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich es hinterherrennen würde. Ich würde es eher Inkonsequenz nennen. Ich glaube, an vielen Stellen ist es gar nicht so, dass man hinkt großartig hinterher, sondern man kann sich einfach nicht für eine echte IT-Sicherheit entscheiden. Man hat immer noch nicht verstanden, dass wenn ich jetzt über IT-Sicherheit rede, dass dann eben Verteidigung auch die beste Verteidigung ist. Und dass ich mir das dann nicht irgendwie so zurechtlege, dass ich den ganzen anderen Kram, den meine Behörden, meine Geheimdienste und sonst wer gerne noch machen würde, irgendwie dann noch ermögliche und damit wieder alles kaputt mache. Also ich glaube, man bräuchte schon mehr Konsequenz und vielleicht nicht mal so sehr dieses sich an irgendeine Spitze von einer Entwicklung stellen.
Ich mach das nächste Fass auf, was du dann gleich anzünden möchtest, weil ich es auch schon mehrfach brandrohnen wollte. Also was man dafür braucht, ist eine ganz klare Cybersicherheitsstrategie. Und wir haben eine Cybersicherheitsstrategie 2016 vom Bundesinnenministerium verarbeitet bekommen.
Welche Farbe hat er das damals?
Union, ja. Also es ist CDU gefärbt und naja, dann weiß er schon meine Meinung dazu. Aber ich sag's trotzdem. Das Ding heißt Cybersicherheitsstrategie 2016. Und es hat nichts, aber auch wirklich gar nichts mit einer Strategie zu tun. Es sind lieblos auf 34 Seiten oder so ein paar Maßnahmen zusammengeklatscht worden, die überhaupt kein strategisches Ziel verfolgen. Keine KPI-Messpunkte, an denen du bewerten willst, ob und welche Punkte du erfüllt hast. Also wirklich lieblos ist das. Ich hab noch nie so ein strategieloses Strategiepapier gesehen. Dafür schäme ich mich. So. Fremdschämen. Und es hat letztes Jahr vier Workshops gegeben, in denen das BMI gesagt hat, ja hier ist Cybersicherheitsstrategie 2021, wir machen ein Update. Und wollen jetzt alle beteiligen. Und dann waren da Sicherheitsbehörden, Professoren, also die Wissenschaft sozusagen. Die AG Critis wurde sogar auch eingeladen und ein paar andere und durften an diesen Workshops teilnehmen. Und dann war ich in zwei von den vieren, weil in den anderen zwei war Ion von der AG Critis mit dabei. Und wir haben uns, also erstmal war so, es wurde immer wieder implizit klar, es gibt eine feste Roadmap, feste Vorgehensweise. Und die haben mal aus initial gesammelten Feedbacks so Thesen aufgeschrieben. Die passten aber irgendwie vorne und hinten nicht. Und dann hat man darüber diskutiert und gesagt, aber diese These, also meinen sie die so oder so? Und man sollte dann von eins bis zehn Punkte dafür abstimmen, wie sehr man diese These vertritt. Und dann haben wir festgestellt an manchen Stellen, diese These ist sinnlos. Da haben nicht nur die Zivilgesellschaftlichen, sondern auch die Wissenschaftler oder teilweise sogar die Sicherheitsbehörden gesagt, ja, wenn das so umgemeint ist, dann ja. Aber wenn das so umgemeint ist, macht das ja keinen Sinn. Und dann haben die aber gesagt, ja, ne, die Frage ist jetzt so, die müssen sie so nehmen, die können wir auch nicht ändern, weil danach geht es ja weiter. Und dann wurde irgendwie nach ewiger Diskussion gesagt, ja, dann würden wir das so und so leicht abwandeln, dann nehmen sie das aus der Sicht. Und trotzdem hieß es dann aber am Ende, ja, wenn sie ihre Meinung abgegeben haben und ihre Bewertung der 1 bis 10 Punkte, dann ist das jetzt abgegeben. Und dann machen wir daraus den Entwurf der Strategie. Und da hatte dann noch ein Wissenschaftler und einer aus den Sicherheitsbehörden nachgefragt und gesagt, ja, Moment, ihr pollt jetzt unser Feedback ab, und wir haben schon gemerkt, dass diese Thesen und Fragen nicht ganz sinnvoll sind. Und dann müsste es doch Folgeworkshops und vielleicht noch mal das Feedback zusammensammeln und gucken. Das wird ja sehr divergent ausfallen. Und da hieß es so, nee, ist nicht vorgesehen in der Roadmap. Mitte nächstes Jahr kommt der Entwurf, und das muss dann bis Ende der Legislaturperiode fertig sein. Und eigentlich haben wir hier einen Wirtschaftsprüfer, der das Programm schon für uns durchzieht. Und links und rechts können wir auch nicht gucken, weil BMI-Zuständigkeit ist nur für hier. Weil wir haben gesagt, da fehlt nebenbei Kommunen, Länder, die Wissenschaft, ist alles vergessen worden in dieser Strategie. Und da hieß es dann, ja, aber da haben wir ja keine Zuständigkeit für. Und die Frage zu sagen, naja, vielleicht hebt man diese Seibesicherheitsstrategie vom BMI einer Zuständigkeit sehr eingeschränkt, vielleicht auf so was wie IT-Planungsrat oder wo auch immer, wo man ganz Deutschland vielleicht mal adressiert, hieß es dann, ja, nee, das ist jetzt hier aufgehangen, und der ist da zuständig, und da können wir ja nicht einfach wegnehmen. Also, und wenn man in diesen Entwurf 2021 reinguckt, Holla, die Waldfee, das ist ungefähr noch gruseliger als das IT-Sicherheitsgesetz 2 mit so manchen Aussagen und Statements, die da drin stehen, das kann man eigentlich auch nur in der Luft zerreißen, da wird keine sinnvolle Strategie rauskommen. Und das heißt, auch für die nächste Zeit gibt es eine strategielose Cyber-Umsetzung dieser Regierung noch.
Vielleicht sollte ich mir in meinen Soundtool hier mal so ein Flammenwerfergeräusch einbauen. Das würde die Sache wahrscheinlich ein bisschen erfahren. Okay, also das heißt, bekämen wir dieselbe GroKo wieder, dann würde das genauso weiterlaufen. Gibt es bei anderen Parteien Bestrebungen, ein, warte, lass es mich umfassen, glaubhafte Bestrebungen, eine langfristige Strategie, sich überhaupt ausdenken zu wollen?
Schweigen.
Es ist auch eine Frage. Moment, aber es ist speziell, ich meine, auch auf die Gefahr hin sozusagen, dass dieser Vergleich, wie alle Vergleiche, mega krass hinkt. Was den Klimawandel angeht, gibt es ja sozusagen Dinge, die wir tun können, also konkrete, großartige Ziele. Und es gibt aber tatsächlich sozusagen ganz klare, langfristige Ansagen, wo wir hinmüssen. Also es gibt ein großes Ziel und daraus leiten sich irgendwie kleinere Ziele etc. Und es scheint es hier also überhaupt gar nicht zu geben.
Weil immer jemand wie der Lindner um die Ecke kommt und dann sagt, digital first, bedenken second und dann denkst du so, oh Gott, gib mir einen Octopus, weil die Finger auf der Hand reichen nicht mehr aus für den Facepalm. Du findest einfach in jeder Partei solche Fails. Und deswegen digitale, wirklich so Cybersicherheitsstrategie für Deutschland. Ich glaube, das ist eine Einöde, da kannst du nur alles anzünden. Brandroden, einmal komplett.
Also wenn das Konzept mich schon grandios gescheitert wäre, würde ich fast sagen, es bräuchte mal so eine Partei, die voll politisch ist, aber da einen Schwerpunkt hat. Meine Güte, ist das frustrierend.
Das Thema selbst ist ja auch in diversen Parteien drin. Auch zum Teil mit größeren Zielen, wobei die Wahlprogramme in der Regel mit konkreteren Maßnahmen beschrieben sind, was in den nächsten vier Jahren passieren soll. Und weniger die weichen Grundsatzpositionen wiedergeben. Es gibt bei vielen Parteien Grundsatzprogramme, und dann gibt es Wahlprogramme, die konkrete Maßnahmen für die nächsten vier Jahre beinhalten. Das ist strukturell schwierig, diese Frage zu beantworten. Zum anderen ist das Thema Cyber-Sicherheit auch so eins, wo man vom Wording her auch ein bisschen gucken muss. Viele sprechen auch gerne von der IT-Sicherheit. Weil Cyber ja auch immer gerne schon ein bisschen militärisch vorgeprägt ist. Ob man jetzt irgendwie die Bundeswehr hat, die dann plötzlich irgendwie in der Kommune schützen soll oder das Kraftwerk von nebenan. Dass die da irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, Soldaten auf die Leitung stellen und dann kontrollieren sie die Pakete. Also ich weiß nicht, wie sie das davor haben, aber wir haben ja sozusagen in allen Parteien, auch gerade in den Oppositionsparteien, viele Vorschläge für präventive, defensive Sicherheitsstrategien. Was man halt machen kann, um auch sozusagen in der Gesellschaft und der Wirtschaft grundsätzlich sichere Kommunikation zu ermöglichen. Das fängt ja bei so Dingen an, wie kann ich mich irgendwo ausweisen, mit einem E-Perso oder mit einem Chip im Handy, um halt irgendwie sicher mir meinen Covid-Zertifikat zu holen. Das sind ja alles so Dinge, wo wir schon an den Basistechnologien scheitern. Und deswegen auch wenig sichere Kommunikation.
Oder willst du grad vielleicht auch nochmal auf eine Luca-App anspielen, die total super und sicher entwickelt wurde, oh mein Gott. Nein, bei mir nicht. Ich hab einen scheiß Thread, der bei Twitter über 830 oder so Einträge inzwischen hat, wie kaputt das alles ist. Du kannst aber so einen Thread eigentlich zu jedem Cyberthema in Deutschland irgendwie bauen. Das ist möglich. Das ist irgendwie unglaublich.
Vielleicht muss ich mal, bevor ich mich in der Frustration vollständig hingebe, ist es eigentlich in anderen Ländern auch so, dass dieses IT-Thema, dieses Digitalisierungsthema immer so ein Rum mehr anderen zwischen FacePalm und Flammenwerfer ist?
Ich glaube tatsächlich, also nicht überall. Es gibt ja schon sehr viele Unterschiede, ob ich jetzt nach Skandinavien gucke oder nach Estland oder in die USA, wo man auch deutlich weniger Föderalismus hat, wo einfach zentral gesagt wird, okay, ich mache jetzt hier so eine Sicherheitsanweisung, halt wegen alle müssen jetzt ihre Exchange Server abschalten und patchen. Das ist in den USA halt quasi eine zentrale Stelle, die das mal rausgibt. Und hier hat man halt so Bund, Länder und Kommunen. Und dann die Beteiligung der Kommunen. Und da arbeitet jeweils die IT-Abteilung für sich selbst, ohne irgendwie großartig mit anderen sich abzustimmen oder gemeinsam Bedienungen zu betreiben. Es gibt natürlich so ein paar gemeinsame Rechenzentren. Aber die Synergieeffekte, die man jetzt in der großen Ordnung hätte, gesamte Verwaltung werden halt gar nicht benutzt.
Ja, aber dafür haben sie im Gegenzug dann so einen US-Präsident Biden, der sich hinstellt und sagt, wenn ihr Cyber-Ingriffe gegen USA fährt, dann werden wir mit kinetischen Wirkmitteln antworten. Und sagt quasi, cybert ihr uns an, schicken wir euch Bomben zurück. Das willst du dann aber eigentlich auch nicht, ne?
Das haben wir glaube ich auch schon in dem Weißbuch gehabt von der NATO 2011 oder so. Ich erinnere mich daran, dass die NATO damals das Wort Haktivisten benutzt hat. Und Haktivisten waren ja auch damals Leute, die irgendwie im Rahmen von dem Arabischen Frühling noch irgendwie Dienste aufgemacht haben oder Web-Sperren umgangen haben und solche Geschichten. Da gab es ja recht viel Aktivismus in dem Bereich.
Okay, also ich will noch ein letztes konkretes Thema anfangen. Vielleicht keine gute Idee, anyways, ich frag's trotzdem. Und zwar, wenn wir über sozusagen IT-Sicherheit sprechen, dann geht's ja auch ein bisschen, sagen, um die Digitalisierung des Verwaltungsapparates. Weil eigentlich will man, dass der Verwaltungsapparat, Behördengänge etc. dass sie digital auch vorangehen können oder auch im Gesundheitssystem. Andererseits fürchtet man sich immer davor, wie denn die Umsetzung aussieht. Und dann ist ja eben auch die Frage, ist das sicher? Könnt ihr was dazu sagen, wie der Stand da ist?
Also wer da ganz viel Langeweile hat, kann der Lilith auf Twitter folgen und sich angucken, wie dermaßen das vor die Wand gefahren wird.
Also es gibt ein Gesetz, das vorschreibt, dass alle Verwaltungsleistungen online gestellt werden müssen, dass man sie quasi online beantragen kann. Als OZG, ne? Da gab es auch eine Frist dazu, die wird aber leider nicht mehr eingehalten. Aber die Idee ist, man macht es erst mal alles online. Das heißt, man baut ein großes Portal, wo man Formulare ausfüllen kann. Und dann müssen die irgendwie ins Backend. Und dass man das Backend vielleicht auch digital haben sollte, das fiel denen dann anschließend auf. Und nun ja, wenn man halt so was strategisch angeht, mit dem Ziel zuerst mal die Webseite mit den Formularen und dann den Rest später, dann zieht es halt so parallel ein bisschen nach, mit ein bisschen Verzögerung. Dann hat man so Komponenten, die online sind, und Komponenten, die nicht online sind, und die noch zusammenwirken müssen. Dann hatte man noch diese Fachverfahren, die doch von sehr kleinen Herstellerbooten erstellt worden sind und auch rundaus laufen und aussehen wie aus den 90ern. Dann ist es halt schwierig, das sozusagen zentral mal neu zu machen. Aber prinzipiell ist diese OZG-Unsetzung ein Riesenthema. Es sind riesige Mittel bewilligt worden. Wobei ein Dienst, alle Verwaltungsleistungen online zu betreiben, nicht nur ein Einmalprojekt ist, sondern eigentlich ein dauerhafter Service. Das wäre schade, wenn das Portal in zwei Jahren abgeschaltet wird. Ich glaube, wir unterhalten sich darüber, wie das finanziert werden soll. Aber jetzt hat man sehr viel Geld ausgegeben, um mal so einen Portalverbund zu bauen mit Servicekonten und anderen Dingen. Aber Security müsste man da auch noch mal mit reindenken. Ich glaube, da gibt es noch keinerlei Sicherheitsrichtlinien oder Erlass, die dazu rausgegeben werden könnten.
Also dazu kann ich ein paar Details geben. Und zwar Ende 2022 ist die Deadline, dass per OZG alles online sein soll. Die Deadline, die du meintest, die gerissen wird. Und im Para 5 hat man ja gesagt, da müssen IT-Sicherheit erforderliche Standards durch Rechtsverordnung des BMI im Ministerium ohne Zustimmung des Bundesrats festgelegt werden. Und da hatte die AG Kritis dann auch mal über frag den Staat die Anfrage gestellt, dass wir mal die Rechtsverordnung sehen dürfen, weil irgendwie gab es die im September 2020 noch nicht. Und das förderte dann zutage, dass diese Rechtsverordnung, die beschreibt, wie die IT-Sicherheitsstandards für die IT-Komponenten aussehen sollen, die für diese digitale Verwaltung gelten soll, noch nicht mal erlassen worden ist. Auch einen Entwurf gab es nicht zu dem Zeitpunkt. Das heißt, die Umsetzung wurde schon lange gemacht oder auch nicht. Aber es gab noch nicht mal die Sicherheitsvorgaben. Und jetzt kann man sich überlegen, selbst wenn es die dann jetzt gibt, das weiß ich gerade aktuell nicht, wird man diese ganzen Verwaltungsdienstleistungen und Fachverfahren nachträglich Sicherheitsreihen verflanschen. Und die Deadline reißt man auch. Das kann schon nicht mehr secure by design, secure by default sein, weil man die Sicherheit als Kopf hinterher schiebt. Und auch da wieder, danke ans BMI, das Innenministerium hat es auch da wieder hingekriegt, Dinge anzünden zu wollen, statt ordentlich umzusetzen.
Ich glaube, auch da braucht es halt eine Strategie, um halt mal grundsätzlich einen Plan zu machen. Weil wenn man verschiedene Projekte startet und nicht weiß, welche zuerst kommen müssen und welche anschließend, dann hat man halt ein paar Jahre später ein Problem.
Hat denn jemand diese Strategie?
Na ja, wir haben ja gerade über die Cyber Security Strategie 2021 gesprochen. Nein.
Okay, also keiner von denen, die an der Macht sind, hat eine Strategie. Aber hat einer von den anderen eine Strategie?
Die kam halt noch nicht in den Genuss, die mal detailliert ausbreiten zu können. Ich glaube, man muss einfach sehr auf die Details gucken. Weil an sich klingt ja alles erstmal gut. Niemand wird sich ja hinstellen und sagen, wir wollen weniger Cyber-Sicherheit. Man will immer mehr und man will immer gute Verschlüsselungen. Man will das immer irgendwie schön made in Germany. Und alles ist schön. Aber ich glaube, es kommt halt so sehr auf die Details an, dass man jetzt aus einem Wahlprogramm nicht ableiten kann, ob jemand die riesige Strategie hat. Und es ist ja auch nicht das super sexy Thema, mit dem man irgendwie politisches Profil in der Öffentlichkeit gewinnt.
Das ist nichts, was eine Partei einfach mal so produziert. Sondern das ist ja was, wo du einen Verweisungsstab brauchst, ein Ministerium, was dir dazu arbeitet, um das mal zu...
Ja, also okay, verstehe ich sozusagen praktisch gesehen. Aber für mich persönlich wäre es interessant, eine Partei zu wählen, die sagt, wir haben das auf dem Schirm. Und wir machen das auch richtig. Und zwar nach folgenden Maßgaben. Na gut, anyways, macht es Sinn, wenn wir jetzt nochmal CDU, SPD, also Union, SPD, Grüne, Linke, FDP durchgehen? Mit dem Wahlprogramm, oder ist eigentlich alles gesagt? Okay, dann, weil ich euch natürlich nicht fragen werde, was ihr wählt, will ich euch aber fragen, könnt ihr aufgrund der Informationen, die euch zur Verfügung stehen, bei diesem Thema eine Gewichtung bei eurer Wahlentscheidung herbeiführen? Oder sagt ihr, das ist eh totaler Quatsch, an dem Thema mach ich das nicht fest, das mach ich an anderen Themen?
Ich mach es auch an diesem Thema fest, aber nicht nur.
Aber das gibt für dich Unterschiede?
Ich würde das auch so sehen. Also, das ist zwar ein wichtiges Thema für mich, aber es gibt ja auch andere Bereiche. Aber es gibt auch Unterschiede zwischen den Parteien.
Das ist ein Missverständnis. Die Frage war nicht, ob das Thema wichtig für euch ist. Die Frage war, unterscheiden sich in dem Punkt die Parteien genug, dass man da eine Auswahl treffen kann?
So hatte ich die Frage verstanden. So hab ich sie auch beantwortet.
Markus? Also, es gibt da durchaus starke Unterschiede zwischen den Parteien. Da kann man auch eine Auswahl treffen. Da kann man sich auch angucken, wer da kandidiert und wer da welche Themen vertritt. Also, da gibt es durchaus große Unterschiede.
Ich würde sagen, die Positivseite unterscheidet sich gar nicht mal so sehr. Für mich hilft es eher, quasi so einen negativen Ausschluss zu machen. Das heißt, einfach klar, wenn jemand aktiv, also mit einem Hackback auf Cyberangriffe, antworten will und das in sein Wahlprogramm schreibt, dann fällt das halt raus. Und ich glaube, auf der Seite von denen, die jetzt eine sinnvolle Äußerung in ihr Wahlprogramm schreiben, sind die Unterschiede gar nicht so riesig in den Themen.
Na gut, dann würde ich es dabei mal belassen wollen. Es ist einfach mega kompliziert. Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, also ich habe auf jeden Fall viel gelernt, aber ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich meine Entscheidungsfindung weitergekommen bin. Aber hey, vielleicht, liebe HörerInnen, geht euch das ja anders. Vielleicht habt ihr noch einen Tipp, den ihr in die Kommentare schreiben könnt. Vielen Dank auf jeden Fall, Honkase, Anna und Markus, dass ihr da wart und euch so geduldig habt ausfragen lassen.
Bitteschön.
Und ihr, liebe HörerInnen, die auch alle WählerInnen seid, euch habe ich noch eine Sache mehr zu sagen. Geht wählen und verschüsselt immer schön eure Backups.